this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up guys michael here the last
couple of years have taught us a lot
like the value of social ties and
community and the value of leading with
spear but mostly we've learned how
absolutely inextricable technology is
from our daily lives and if one harvard
dropout has his way the boundary between
our physical and digital selves is only
going to get blurrier in short our
future looks and feels more like science
fiction than ever before maybe that's
not so surprising the most powerful
people in tech from the co-founders of
google to elon musk invariably cite
famous works of sci-fi as formative
influences and while sci-fi has its fair
share of cool lasers and sleek hairdos
it's also uniquely positioned to explore
big ideas so what happens when these big
ideas influence the rich and powerful
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
how tech bros get sci-fi so wrong oh and
spoilers ahead for a few great works of
sci-fi and uh the future of humanity
but before we get into it i want to tell
you about this week's sponsor keeps
keeps makes it easier and more
affordable for guys to prevent hair loss
and since two out of three men will
experience hair loss in some form by the
time they're 35
keeps is relevant to a lot of people out
there but with their subscription
service you can fight back and hang on
to the locks you've got the keeps
process begins with a free consultation
with a licensed keeps doctor who can
help decide which combination of fda
approved prescriptions and
over-the-counter medications are right
for you these medications will arrive at
your doorstep every three months so you
don't have to leave your house to pick
up refills as your treatment plan goes
on you can message your keeps doctor 24
7 to update them on your progress and to
ask any questions you may have but
here's one question we can answer right
off the bat while individual results may
vary it typically takes between four and
six months to start seeing results if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to
keeps.comwisecrack or click the link in
the description to receive fifty percent
off your first order that's keps.com
wisecrack now back to the show sci-fi
has always inspired real world tech
what's arguably the first sci-fi movie
fritz lang's 1929 film woman in the moon
helped humanity add space flight to its
to-do list rocketry pioneer hermann
oberth consulted with lang to envision
the space shuttle bringing in ideas like
multi-stage rockets and the takeoff
countdown that for both practical and
aesthetic reasons have become
foundational to space travel the movie
was also beloved by america's pet nazi
warner von braun who went on to design
the apollo spacecraft in the wider view
countless figures across science tech
and industry including edwin hubble cite
early sci-fi novelist jules verne as a
key inspiration one of the apollo 8
astronauts frank borman even went so far
as to say that in a very real sense
jules verne is one of the pioneers of
the space age today's technologists are
no different they invariably cite both
classic and contemporary sci-fi as
formative inspirations much of silicon
valley treats the neil stevenson novel
snow crash as some kind of holy text
that includes mark zuckerberg who
apparently made it required reading for
new recruits elon musk says that isaac
asimov's foundation was key to his
founding spacex and is open about his
love of douglas adams hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy series and peter thiel has
described his vision of the future as
uniquely inspired by sci-fi writer
robert a heinlein it's no surprise that
an industry dominated by nerds has some
geeky shared interest but while sci-fi
is a wise genre some works are invoked a
lot more than others in addition to the
aforementioned foundation series and
snow crash star trek rounds out the big
three perhaps more so than any other
work snow crash has wielded incredible
influence over silicon valley everyone
who's anyone in tech has named it as a
big inspiration from google co-founders
sergey brin and larry page to peter
thiel and perhaps most faithfully mark
zuckerberg it's easy to see why they're
all so keen on it a key part of the
novel's world is the metaverse a sort of
digital wild west where coders and
techies reign supreme with just a vr
headset and a steady internet connection
people can live almost entirely in the
metaverse coming out only for short
periods to do dumb [ __ ] like eat and
learn their children's names
and if people like the zuck get their
way the metaverse will soon become a
thing we can't ignore he even changed
his company's name to meta to show just
how committed he is and game platforms
like fortnite and roblox are both
inspired by and trying to manifest their
own versions of the metaverse then
there's foundation which elon musk in
particular has lauded calling it
fundamental to the creation of spacex
the tldr foundation is one big brain man
is so good at math that he can
accurately predict the future he
discovers that the galactic empire is
doomed so he takes a bunch of the best
scientists to another planet to build a
new empire a scientific meritocracy the
series is rooted in that old chestnut
american exceptionalism which as your
seventh grade social studies teacher
told you it basically just means america
is uniquely great this notion especially
took off after world war ii where
america established its dominance in its
early chapters foundation seems to
endorse this view but asimov wrote the
foundation series over a long period
with a nearly three decade gap in the
middle and the core ideas he
communicated changed to reflect the
times by the end of his series
foundation had challenged the post-war
ideas at its core exploring the follies
of imperialism and exceptionalism within
the context of the second galactic
empire basically the protagonists
initial goal of single-handedly starting
this new world is sharply critiqued in
fact asimov made it well known that he
based the overall arc of the series on
the history of the decline and fall of
the roman empire but the big boys of
silicon valley also have some more
mainstream sci-fi interests take star
trek we probably don't need to explain
this classic to you with its utopian
federation of planets and exploration of
complex social and philosophical issues
it's a series defined by its idealism
and total standing of justice and
equality people who worked with steve
jobs named his ability to push you to do
seemingly impossible things his reality
distortion field a term straight out of
the track and real life scrooge mcduck
jeff bezos has been outspoken about the
influence the show has had on him he
almost named amazon makeitso.com
after picard's famous catchphrase make
it so and the complex voice control
computers of the enterprise were a
direct inspiration for alexa perhaps
most tellingly bezos ended his high
school valedictorian speech with a star
trek quote he said space the final
frontier
meet me there bezos also tacitly forced
william shatner to look at his childhood
trek fan art billionaires they're just
as embarrassing as us so we've
established the enormous influence
sci-fi has had on silicon valley and hey
in some ways knowing that these people
enjoy genre is kind of cool and when
some of the most powerful people in the
world are sci-fi nerds it's going to
have an impact on the culture but even
if they share the interest of the hoi
polloi their lives are so radically
different from ours that they may be
taking away something totally different
from our shared sci-fi faves let's go
back to snow crash which is set in a
real world dystopia everyone lives in
burb claves which are described as a
city-state with its own constitution a
border laws cops everything everything
within these burb claves has been
corporatized including the law meaning
that big corporations can say legally
kill you for minor criminal infractions
so if you work for say amazon you would
likely live in the amazon verb clay in
the world of snow crash corporations
basically have full control over
government and society not that this
could ever happen in our world and this
has forced those seeking freedom into
the metaverse a place free from
corporate control it's essentially an
anarchist technocracy and the only
boundaries are set by the technology you
have access to this is where companies
like meta miss the point because even if
other companies contribute to the
metaverse meta is always going to have
more control if they host the servers if
their infrastructure is what it's built
upon then the metaverse will never be
free from corporate oversight that isn't
going to allow anyone with enough coding
shops to mess around with the source
code because the company has invested
time money and brain power into its
design the metaverse of zuckerberg's
dream is one that's been divided up into
multiple corporate controlled walled
gardens each with their own terms of
service and currencies this ironically
resembles the hellish corporate reality
of snow crash more than its anarchist
digital metaverse here a tech
billionaire with the unique ability to
turn a sci-fi vision into reality seems
to have missed the critique at the heart
of that fictional vision and this isn't
the only example of a tech bro missing
some vital points from their favorite
content take foundation when musk talks
about escaping climate change by moving
humanity to mars a feat that only he is
brave or willing enough to undertake
it's easy to see the connection musk
gets to step into the role of the big
brain man who anticipates our doom and
works as a private entity to solve the
problem but in being the man who built
and therefore owns and operates his
proposed martian colony musk also takes
the role of the head of the meritocracy
he contributed the most so he's in
charge however in painfully ironic news
that's the very concept that the
foundation series explicitly disavows
but in musk's fantasy he is the
exceptional man with both an idea and
the scientific know-how to realize it
every launch that spacex undertakes has
the underlying goal of building towards
mars colonization but a one-man-led
colonization mission and foundation
isn't the solution it's a recipe for
social collapse so not exactly something
the average tech billionaire should be
looking to imitate right but we do have
one tech bro whose role model is
objectively a pretty good guy
and a true bald king
jeff bezos is such a big trekker that he
says he idolizes enterprise captain
jean-luc picard which is interesting
because picard is defined by his strong
sense of ethics and morals arguably even
more than other captains in the series
whereas kirk is brash and headstrong
picard is measured and deliberate kirk
will make mistakes and do the right
thing eventually while picard will
agonize over the decision to avoid
making the mistake in the first place
now we're not claiming that bezos
doesn't consider all his options before
making a decision you don't get to be a
big time capitalist baron without
thinking things through but there is a
disconnect between the example that
picard sets and bezos's public facing
actions here's a couple of picard quotes
to show what we mean and first contact
he says the acquisition of wealth is no
longer the driving force in our lives
we work to better ourselves
and the rest of humanity
in next generation he says first time
any man's freedom
is trodden
we're all damaged
and also in next generation i have to
weigh the good of the many
against the needs of the individual and
try to balance them
as realistically as possible these
aren't outliers they all demonstrate
picard's fundamental character he's all
about altruism and bettering mankind at
large in contrast jeff bezos has a
literally unspendable amount of personal
wealth which he keeps adding to it's
fine being the second wealthiest person
in the world that actually worked fine
and amazon has roundly been exposed for
exploiting workers regardless of your
stance on those issues and whether or
not you agree with picard bezos's
actions are clearly contradictory to the
fictional man he idolizes if picard were
real and he met bezos it's clear he'd
bar his application to the federation so
who cares if figures like musk
zuckerberg and bezos are big old sci-fi
nerds with poor critical reading skills
honestly
everybody should due to their outsized
influence on government and society this
implication is especially stark when you
compare the wealth of these heads of big
tech to say
national space agencies like nasa which
are vastly underfunded so our forays
into the galaxy are yoked into a
billionaire space race that's enmeshed
with the egos of the pros involved
what's more big tech has a ridiculous
amount of money to spend on lobbying
tailoring legislation to best suit their
needs arguably at the expense of
everybody else zuckerberg and meta are
already trying to colonize the internet
and developing nations transforming it
into some vr driven hyper-monetized
corporate land that would fundamentally
change how we interact with one another
digital platforms have become a key
aspect of our social interactions and
the people in charge of them have
relative freedom to do whatever they
want zuckerberg and the metaverse musk
and his mars colonies bezos and wearing
cowboy hats they're all billionaire
passion projects that either are or have
the potential to fundamentally change
reality for all of us in ways both
tangible and conceptual driven by their
love for but perhaps not coherent
understanding of sci-fi these platforms
are shaping the world we live in and
what we imagine the future could look
like with so much at stake perhaps it's
no wonder that william gibson one of the
most prophetic sci-fi authors of all
time once said that he has explicitly
decided not to write certain ideas into
his books because he worried that they'd
be misunderstood and possibly imitated
and who are we to not listen to the
wisdom of the original cyberpunk but
what do you guys think apart from using
anti-trust laws to break up tech
monopolies making them pay their taxes
and revoking all of their library cards
is there anything that can be done
should we do anything at all or are they
free to take what they want from sci-fi
and throw away what doesn't suit let us
know what you think in the comments
big thanks to our patrons and be sure to
check out our podcast hit that subscribe
button like you're hitting the emergency
power off switch to the metaverse and
don't forget to ring that bell as always
thanks for watching
and we'll see you in space
[Music]
you